so there's been a lot of discussion of
if and when joe biden is going to
denounce
violence that is taking place in
different places around the country
and the trumpists and donald trump
himself have focused in a lot on this
why won't joe biden denounce this why
won't joe biden denounce that
now before we get to the sort of
substance
here which is that joe biden did it and
a lot of people on the left are furious
with him
and the right is just simply ignoring it
does joe biden really need to denounce
anything
in the sense that we currently have
violence happening
under the leadership of donald trump and
even though donald trump is trying to
insist that
violence is what's in store in biden's
america
if you look back at when biden was vice
president things were relatively calm
and the violence that we are seeing now
to the extent that it exists
is a a lot of it is being done by trump
supporters of course not all of it but
it is all happening
as donald trump is president of the
united states but okay
let's put that we'll table that argument
for now
and let's just say people want biden to
denounce
the violence well he did it joe biden
did it in a speech
in pennsylvania and trumpists are just
pretending that he didn't do it and some
of the left is furious so what i want to
discuss with you after we look at the
clip is
did this make sense uh let's take a look
at what joe biden had
to say rioting is not protesting
looting is not protesting setting fires
is not protesting none of this is
protesting
it's lawlessness plain and simple
and those who do it should be prosecuted
violence will not bring change it will
only bring destruction
it's wrong in every way it divides
instead of unites
destroys businesses only hurts the
working families that serve the
community
it makes things worse across the board
not better
no it's not what uh dr king or john
lewis taught
and it must end so on the facts
i agree with joe biden here rioting is
not protesting looting is not protesting
and setting fires is not protesting in
the sense that it will bring productive
change now i know that there are people
who will respond and say
you don't get to set the terms of what
counts as protesting okay well we'll get
to that in a little bit
but the possible folly of joe biden
doing this is that
the right is just pretending he didn't
do it they're continuing to say why
won't joe biden
denounce violence even though he's done
it and there's a slice of the left that
is absolutely furious with joe biden
here now i'm not saying it's all the
left or a huge portion but
it's certainly a very loud slice of the
left particularly
online and the reason that some on the
left are mad at joe biden for doing this
is
they say that he's playing into the idea
that it's his supporters who are being
violent the the idea being
by joe biden coming out and saying no
matter who's doing it i'm against the
violence
it sort of frames it up as joe biden
acknowledging that it is his supporters
being violent and telling them to stop
uh i think that there are two sides to
this so first of all
i find it completely reasonable and
unproblematic that joe biden says
violence is bad and i'm against it
it's insane that it has to be said
but he said it and he said no matter who
does the violence i'm against the
violence
but the second piece is that it's
important to clarify at every
opportunity
that almost nobody on the left is being
violent that a lot of the violence
is provocateurs and right wingers and i
hate to say this but
by and large the leftists that are being
violent
are overwhelmingly not people supporting
joe biden
and often individuals who see joe biden
as as much of a problem
or almost as much of a problem as donald
trump
so if there is a criticism of joe biden
here
it's that he arguably
indirectly or implicitly seems to be
acknowledging or conceding that some of
his supporters are being violent and i
really don't think that that's the case
at all i've not
really seen evidence of that so i don't
believe there's any problem with joe
biden
denouncing violence in principle i do
think it's sort of like when
you know there's an islamic terror
attack and right winger starts saying
why didn't this individual muslim person
who had nothing to do with it denounce
the violence well
most people denounce violence implicitly
most people are against violence i don't
know whether that
uh is even something that should be
expected particularly when joe biden
isn't in power and there's no evidence
that it is his supporters that are doing
anything but
what i would like to see more of is joe
biden aggressively placing the blame
where it should be placed biden
should be saying or let me go back there
are people saying
by doing this joe biden is hinting that
he's going to police and limit protests
as president
and limit free speech that's not at all
what biden is doing here and in fact
the obama biden administration had a
completely normal relationship with the
press
trump is the one that's authoritarian
and dystopian
when it comes to a free press and
ultimately this is a
sort of discussion of the martin luther
king perspective
on protests versus the malcolm x
perspective
and one of the things that most
resonates with me that dr king
often said was the problem
with going to looting arson violence
as a form of protest is not whether it's
morally defensible
maybe it is that's a perfectly
reasonable conversation to have
but the small percentage who choose to
do it
often end up hurting themselves and when
protests
go to violence looting etc
it very often backfires and hurts the
very people that we are trying to help
through our activism that was this is
martin luther king's view
and you can extensively find interviews
with him on youtube where he says that
that's my take on it so on the facts i
do tend to agree with joe biden
i think the framing of biden must
announce biden must denounce he does and
they just
keep saying biden must denounce as if he
didn't do it
that's where it starts to get a little
problematic